i've not spoken to michael griffin in
quite some time he and brian arakbo
um who i covered back in the day on nfl
network
are uh taking part in a show on food
network
uh 1 eastern time 12 central streaming
the same day on
discovery plus as well cupcake guys
training camp
where the last baker standing wins a 10
000
seed investment in their business
michael griffin two-time pro bowler
tennessee titans safety back in the day
here on the rich eisen show how have you
been michael i've been good i've been
good you know i think everybody's been
dealing with the pandemic that's going
on in the world but uh
just blessed to be with my my friends
and my family and my kids and enjoying
life you know there's this
life outside of football that i never
really knew that existed
while i was playing the game of football
since i was five years old so i was 33
years old so are your kids are the kids
are the kids getting
the ones that got you into baking or
you're the head baker here
right i am i like to call myself the
head baker uh when we got into this
business we we had to get our feet wet
and we had to learn the business and and
being pro athletes and you know i say
egos and guys trying to excel at
everything that we do because of that
competitive nature you have to learn the
ends and the outs so
uh with this business it was we started
with a franchise to learn business
and uh and to work our way up from the
grounds up but as a franchise they
already have a foundation in place so
you get to kind of get to
get that cheat code of understanding how
this business operates so if we want to
move forward and go past
um we kind of know how business work
operates and things of that nature so
i know the nfl provides uh you know
business school and things of that
nature but
there's nothing like really getting your
feet wet and and walking
you know the steps and seeing what it
takes place to actually run a business
instead of you see a lot of professional
athletes who open up a business but they
get friends and family and everybody
else to run it for them because they
don't know exactly what to do
but somebody has that bright idea but
our bright idea was hey we're going to
be in this all together and
you know there's there's no man that's
going to let one man do more than the
other so it's three of us and it's been
going
going great for us for the last three
years well the three of you um
little brian heintzen you're is that a
lifelong best friend of you and uh
and brian orakpo who if i'm not mistaken
i've never heard of brian rakpo referred
to as a lead cupcake decorator but uh
here we are is that what we yeah it's
funny because uh you would think
somebody who has a mean pass rush
especially
you see defensive lineman and outside
linebackers slap
you know you know but he it's it's
amazing he's he's very
uh when he's you know with the baking
bag and stuff he's he's
very soft with pushing out the icing and
things in that niche and uh he's got the
touch brian henson
the best thing about brian henson is you
know he's been in this this world you
know from day one he's been
um the manager and gm's of car
dealerships and things of that nature
okay he knows how the business works so
you know i advise people when you do
want to
you know get your feet wet and learn and
and start a business be an entrepreneur
you know
navigate and work your way through you
know filter out your friends and see who
who
really holds benefits and holds value to
what your
with your ideas that you're coming up
with in your game plans and things of
that nature all right before i ask you
about super bowl 55 one last question on
your on your adventure here uh
your go-to cupcake what's the go-to
cupcake my go-to
cup it might be the italian cream cheese
uh we have so many different flavors i'm
not a big chocolate fan myself but
if you like chocolate chip cookie dough
uh double stuff which is like a oreo oh
peanut butter
we got so many different options but uh
my go-to is the
italian cream cheese or we got a
kentucky bourbon where we actually put
uh some bourbon in there
and we bake it with the bourbon and also
in the frosting so um
occasionally when i'm you know there by
myself and i want to just get a little
and drink but without drinking just add
a little bit more of the burping in
there
how about that kind of does the trick
for you yeah it does
kentucky bourbon we have tequila to
cupcakes too so we we do a little bit of
everything we
we spice it up a little bit here and
there we got it for all ball tricks in
the trades you know
adults kids whatever it may be we have
options for everybody
italian cream cheese is that what you
said
yes italian cream cheese cream cheese
frosting it's a white coconut cake
um with a little sour cream it's it's a
it's oh my god it's i had it for my
birthday this year so yes
it's kind of good also when you can bake
for your own kids and make your own
birthday cakes and things of that nature
so
saves you a lot of money well it's great
again that you're helping uh aspiring
entrepreneurs achieve their their dreams
it's a good thing you're helping strahan
on that what an in he's such an
inspiring uh entrepreneur
uh i can't believe it definitely you
know i mean it's a it's a it's amazing
that stray is actually producing a show
i mean normally he's just lazing around
the house doing nothing with his life
so um it's impressive what he's doing
with you guys well
it's definitely impressive i mean just
being able to you know first
play it against him but then when you
get to meet him talk to him to see all
the different things that he has going
on it sure does
you know you see see you see them on the
nf you know you see them you know
brought
for nfl then you see them doing
interviews and you see them on
um good morning america you see them
everywhere so it's like
i'm like hey when do you get time to
spend time with your family when do you
get time and he's like
as soon as i leave here i'm getting
another suit on i'm jumping on the plane
i'm going here
you know but again be successful you got
to be hard working you got to put the
same
amount of effort and work ethic that you
did to to be where you at today and
again
even watching yourself you know it takes
time it's a lot of hard work it's not
easy but to see how everybody continues
to climb that ladder and help everybody
out
how do you think super bowl 55 winds up
michael griffin break it down
well i was just thought you were saying
a little bit the weather and things in
that nature so it's gonna be uh
see who has the best running game i
think fournette's been coming
having you know he's been coming into
his own as of late um
we know paige uh we know we know tampa
bay loves and brady loves to play action
pass uh so they may be able to continue
to get that going depending on how
antonio brown how healthy he is to have
that you know third
extra receiver out there with godwin and
uh
and number 13 but uh again this this is
like uh
one of those games like is the torch
being passed
or is it the the goats gonna continue to
keep it so uh
i just we all know it's about the
turnovers last year
san francisco pretty much had it but as
soon as kansas city started getting
creating those turnovers they was able
to you know
get the ball rolling and we know uh
patrick holmes
you know he can play from behind we saw
that last year
versus uh tennessee titans we saw it
also versus the uh
the houston texans he can play from
behind so
they are a team that can score very
quick so um
i think i'm just looking for a good
exciting game i'm not going
i'm not allowed to accept that michael
griffin this is not look at this
i'm looking for an exciting game you
remember i wasn't i wasn't a fan of the
rams versus the patriots it was just too
boring for me
it was like nothing going on no i know
that i get it michael griffin but this
is not a cupcake shop this is there's
there's no italian cream cheese or
or or oreo double stuff choices you
must have one choice who wins super bowl
55.
who you got patrimo i think patrick
mahomes gonna get this one
okay gonna take this one you go i'm
gonna get this one there you go i really
do
i gotta do it i bet i bet i better the
kid i bet this kid at the local grocery
store
he he he just came like i know who you
are and i was like okay nice meeting you
and he just
charged me up and i was like well then
put your money where your mouth is
and he said i know who you are i know
you got a lot of money and i said well
how much you willing to lose
and he's like i got tampa bay so i got
to go with kansas city right now okay i
hope it's a good game but i got to go
with kansas city so i can
but i told him if i win there was
another young lady that was bagging my
groceries
i said if i win you're going to give her
the money
yeah i love it i don't want to come
looking for you i want you to give her
the money
so you're going to have to pay her but
if i if i lose i will be here
monday morning and i'll have your money
in the envelope so
but again hopefully this young lady is
blessed with fifty dollars
uh tip i love it it's bagging my
groceries hey before i let you go what
are you in a rakbo think of sarc
taking over the longhorn football
program what do you think of this
i'm excited i'm excited uh we got to
have a conversation with him and uh
he's he he's he's humble uh
and i think the kids are gonna love him
um he
very out spoken about you know his past
he does he's not shy he didn't shy from
it and uh and i think you know when
you see a coach is very genuine like mac
brown
um and some of the other coaches that i
had when i played in ron rivera
another one uh guys that i play with you
you see how genuine they are it it
allows you know
players let alone kids to want to play
for you
and and and they will do anything and
everything for you so
i'm very excited i think he's assembling
a real
good good and nice coaching staff and uh
you saw the national championship game i
mean whoever his play makers is he's
gonna get them the ball oh yeah
make sure so uh we got a young kid by
the name of b john robinson and
hopefully he's probably be up for the
heisman the next few years he
he got i think the last two games he had
over 700 yards
total rushing or three games he had over
700 yards and
uh about six or seven touchdowns so i'm
sure that's going to be his workhorse
and uh again i'm excited um hopefully
texas
can get back to where it used to be i
know a lot of us longhorns have been
living in the past but hopefully we can
start living in the future in the
present so um
i'm excited to see what what goes and
what he can do with this uh
upcoming team well michael uh i
appreciate the time i always like
leaving a guest better than when i found
him um
good luck with uh cupcake guys training
camp on uh
on on this weekend on food network at 12
uh one eastern time and then on
discovery plus as well uh leaving you in
a better way what about a bevo cupcake
you know the top of the cupcake or the
or the the horns what do you think what
do you think of that we will
we will have that but right now we're
definitely we're doing we know that uh
kansas city is known
for their dirt cake okay you know that
tampa bay is known for their key lime
pie cupcake so
if you're in the austin area if you're
listening uh be sure to stop by because
i did just bake some i
baked some cupcakes uh yesterday and i'm
gonna bake some more some key lime
and we did our own little type of oreo
type thing that we're doing
i mean we're here in l.a what do we got
a gold bellian over here what are we
going to do
the next time i come to l.a i'll be sure
to come knock on
there's something called uh shipping
yeah right next day
come on listen i don't have a problem
going to la la is a great city and i'm
not saying
you personally bring it put it you know
ship it little gold belly
i think if i can tell the wife that i
hey i got to go take
i got to take it you know i think she'd
be really really
this is why you're with stray it's all
about branding and next level stuff i
understand uh
thanks for the call michael thanks for
the call appreciate all you have a good
read
catches send my best to brian that's it
thank you it's been a long time since i
spoke to brian orakpo and his
deep barry white dulcet tones again
check out
cupcake guys training camp
food network hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here